you should have one goal to make images
look as beautiful as they can on the
user's device while using as little
bandwidth as possible now this last
point is critical network bandwidth is
most assuredly not free particularly on
mobile devices we'll learn more about
that in the next lesson on performance
and in our final lesson on offline
if you didn't care about bandwidth you
could just serve massively large images
all the time
but a full screen image for a chromebook
pixel is 4.1 megapixels whereas on a
nexus 4 it's only 0.9 megapixels iphone
5 is only 0.7
the best size for images is very
different on each of these devices